foreign
[Music]
opponent and again we have white
okay so we're going to start with E4
and we're rated 1333 good rating and
we're facing the Scandinavian great the
first time I think in the speedrun that
we have faced the scandi correct me if
I'm wrong of course the move is he takes
D5 and Knight F6 this is like the poor
man's candy I I think it might be called
the Portuguese there is a line here
that's called the Portuguese Gambit this
is not it this is again but technically
yes but white is not supposed to keep
the extra Pawn so first of all you might
ask well why not why not simply c2c4
so the reason is that black responds
with C6 and it's important to have
command of basic positional principles
to even understand how this sacrifice
Works after C6 white can transpose to
the panoff Karo Khan I'll show you after
the game or White can play D takes C6
which is the greedy approach but in the
resulting position again I'll show you
the position after the game Black's got
massive control over the center in
particular a stronghold on D4 and
White's got a terrible light squirt
Bishop that's just biting on the C4 Pawn
so there's a variety of factors that
give black tremendous compensation for
the pawn and so the line that you might
have seen me play in Blitz actually my
coach taught me this line years and
years ago it served me very well it's
easy to learn and it's cool it
demonstrates some positional principles
we start by checking on B5 which is kind
of weird it's weird that the first move
we make is with a bishop
but the check itself should make sense
to you it's it's the developing move
with tempo and obviously if black plays
C6 now then of course we play DC and we
haven't pushed the seatbon up to C4 so
that makes no sense for black black can
cover the check in one of two ways there
is Knight B to D7 here which is a viable
move
but most people go Bishop D7 and then
the idea is hey that Bishop on D7 is it
well placed well absolutely not it's
depriving the B8 Knight of a square it's
cutting the contact between Black's
queen and the center it's just standing
in the middle of absolutely everything
and that Bishop absolutely sucks we
should leave it there right and this is
kind of the idea of provoking a
particular move that ends up being
counterproductive to the opponent now
you might logically then reason that we
should play Bishop back to C4 if we're
already moving the bishop well perhaps
we should defend the pawn while we're at
it and I'll show you some Theory after
the game but Bishop C4 is not the move I
was taught it is a reasonable move
but after Bishop C4 it allows Bishop to
G4 that's the problem and Bishop to G4
well what does it do it attacks the
queen it puts the bishop on a better
square and while we can play F3 there
that's not a move you want to be making
in the opening and we might also not be
able to keep our extra Pawn on D5 so how
do we circumvent that well a lot of you
guys are not fully understanding the
point of what I just said you're
proposing Queen E2 or A4 and these are
moves which give black a way out right
they're they allow the bishop tray they
allow black to eradicate this awkward
piece on D7 so we actually physically
need to move the bishop away and we move
it to E2 in order to stop Bishop G4 and
that was a very kind of verbose
explanation of this line but I'm trying
to lay the groundwork so that you don't
forget why this move is played because
this is an easy move to butcher
okay so the idea is to stop Bishop G4
and the idea of moving the bishop at all
is so that after a move like A4 black
doesn't rid himself of this awkward
piece by agreeing to the bishop trade
and then taking on D5 let's say with the
queen now Queen E2 does prevent the
immediate Bishop takes B5 because this
is a fork but after Queen E2 white would
play uh or black would play Just Knight
takes D5 right and ask you what you're
doing on B5
so we continue by occupying the center
with our Pawn we play D4 and it's
important to start with D4 because if
you play the slightly sloppy Knight F3
you allow the extra option of the Knight
jumping into F4
and suddenly like the bishop is under
Fire and G2 is under Fire so we should
prevent that and grab the center at the
same time now you would be correct if
you're kind of assuming that we're going
to play C4 we're going to do that we
don't have to do that immediately that
that move is not going to be taken away
from us but C4 is going to come and it's
going to push the Knight away from D5
and we're gonna have nice development
and better central control and White's
gonna have a small but stable advantage
that's going to be the road map in this
position now we should start here with a
simple developing move let's get the
night out to F3 and then actually let's
castle and only then I think we should
play C4 although
conversely you could say here we're
giving black actually an extra option
it's not like scary but black can play
Bishop f8 to D6 intending to meet C4
with Knight to F4
so that is an option that we've provided
to black but it's we'll find a way
around it we don't have to play C4
against Bishop D6
so our next move likely to be castles
and then C4 and Knight C3 and the
development in this line is very simple
but I like the way our opponent is
handling this C5 is a good move black
contests the center and black basically
forces our hand right
I just said that our next move is going
to be the castle and castling here is
fine but I think
the opportune moment has come to play
what move right we should try to meet
black in the center we shouldn't just
give black free reign in the center we
should try to fight for the center and
we should do it by playing C4 let's
knock the Knight out immediately if we
Castle instead black will take on D4 and
then simply go Knight C6 and by the time
we go C4 black might have some weird
tactics going on that might make C4 less
effective so let's do it now while black
still hasn't completed their development
and uh then we'll castle and proceed
with our development ourselves
okay so if Knight before then we can
just play A3 that's not dangerous there
are some lines in like the alkyne and
scandi where if the bishop uh the light
Square Bishop is on F5 then Knight B4 is
actually a very unpleasant move to face
because it threatens a fork black plays
Knight F6 okay well again we have
Alternatives here we can play Knight to
C3 which we're gonna play we can castle
that's also possible now the move D5
might look very appealing oh let's let's
push the pawn down create a passer but
D5 is actually totally innocuous because
black can trade and if you have a pass
Pawn that's isolated this early in the
game it's likely to be a liability it's
not actually going anywhere because
black and blockade it by putting the
dark squared Bishop on D6 so instead of
hastily rushing forward let's keep the
tension by developing our pieces and
playing Knight C3 and obviously CD we
recapture with the Knight right
recapturing with a queen just doesn't
make much sense
uh because it walks right into Knight C6
what are we scandi players you know John
Bartholomew would recommend Queen takes
D4 and queen H4 but we're keeping things
principled and we're playing by the book
okay
Knight C6 now an important rule that I
have echoed already many times in the
speed run is just because throughout all
of the speed runs is just because an
idea doesn't work in one position
doesn't mean you should rule it out in
another right
circumstances and chess change very
quickly like a single move can make an
idea suddenly work it can rot it can
bring an idea up from the dead and this
is a great example of that right now D5
it makes perfect sense to play this move
because this is the way that we keep the
initiative going it's a Tempo move it
attacks the Knight but most importantly
it doesn't give black the time that he
needs to put his pants on with Bishop D6
right because by the time black plays
that move well first of all we can
prevent black from playing that move by
doing what what development move is
going to prevent Bishop D6 well it's
obviously the move Bishop F4 which we
could throw in and that's a move we want
to play anyway
and you might say well why is it
important that we're preventing Bishop
D6 well that's because Bishop D6 is the
only way to blockade this past Pawn so
if you can imagine after Bishop F4
Bishop E7 D6 the bishop is literally
almost trapped
so at this point the past Pawn has
suddenly become a great asset 94 makes
no sense that just blunders upon we have
two attackers on the D4 Square
so immediately our opponent reacts
in in a panicked way to the pressure and
blunders upon right this is how quickly
you can get players to crumble if you
play principled openings and you just
follow the freaking rules you know
so black now has to tread very carefully
because again Bishop B7 we drive the
pawn down to D6
he goes Bishop B4 that's a good move
now what should we do here should we go
D6
well we can play D6 but D6 seems a lot
less impressive when it doesn't gain a
Tempo or drive the bishop back I
actually don't like D6 because of this
weird move Queen B6
and the idea should be clear you're
trying to force a queen trade and then
the pawn is without a guardian and black
is coming in with Knight E4 that seems
too concrete we should just castle and
we shouldn't play A3 right I would draw
a parallel with the E4 B6 game it's in
the previous speedrun video or two
videos ago I guess
where we we don't need to deal with the
pin by forcibly chasing the bishop away
we can just take the sting out of it by
castling right now the Knight can move
and what we ultimately want is for Black
to take on C3 himself uh because that
loses a Tempo in comparison with A3
another very interesting subtle point I
think you guys will enjoy if we play A3
here we take away the A3 Square from our
Bishop and you might say well how is the
bishop ever going to get that square
well guess what if black takes on C3
himself then after BC our dark squared
Bishop actually has a very nice
developing post on A3 which we don't
really want to take away with the pawn
and that's an example of a super minor
positional point that I would
incorporate into my thinking if I'm
let's say a GM right you'd make these
small observations like oh I don't want
to play A3 because you know maybe I'll
need that square for one of my minor
pieces five moves later I don't know
but you try to play with maximum
flexibility and make the least amount of
commitments possible and you continue
doing that in this position by
developing your pieces right the best
way to make good moves without
committing is just to develop so what
developing move remains well it's to
develop the dark Squad Bishop where
should we put it well that's pretty
obvious from this position Bishop G5 as
it did in the in the previous like
million games uh and we seem to be doing
this like with both colors every game
right this pin is super underrated it's
it's actually an incredibly dangerous
pin in most situations where black is
Castle of kingside and it's even more
dangerous here because the queen is
pressuring the Knight and the Knight 94
is a huge threat as well and let's not
forget that Bishop E7 which I've pre
previously pointed out as a way to take
the sting out of the pin fails in this
position to D5 D6
okay H6 well again we can trade we can
play Bishop takes F6 but it's a little
bit early to trade Queens here because
trading Queens really relieves the
pressure on Black's position if we were
a piece up
if the bishop wasn't on B4 I would
Advocate an approach of simplification
but when you're upon up
that rule kind of goes out the window in
many cases when you're a pawn up you
actually don't want to trade Queens when
you're a piece up in most cases a queen
trade does help you simplify the
position so we just keep the tension
with Bishop H4
and if black plays G5 well that is an
amazing thing to provoke in this
position which already sucks for black
imagine if black also weakens the Knight
and weakens the King permanently that's
just going to be too much to handle
and of course Bishop B7 is played nicely
walking into our idea and what I love is
that the past Pawn ends up deciding the
game the game is not decided if black
finds a small tricky move but then we
can respond with an accurate move of our
own and end the game so what tricky idea
does black have here and I think our
opponent is likely to play this move
so notice that the Queens are in an
x-ray
well Queen B6 Amir white can just take
the queen and take the bishop right
that's not very tricky I'm talking about
Bishop C6
and anytime the Queens are in a file
you're always looking for tactics that
try to exploit the undefended nature of
one of the Queens so Bishop C6 precludes
takes C7 that gives up the queen on D4
for insufficient material what should we
do against Bishop C6 and there is a
muppua here as my sixth grade math
teacher would say most popular wrong
answer there's a move which looks
surface level tempting but then there is
a move which actually wins the game
and let's see if anybody falls for the
tempting move
nobody's falling for the tempting move I
love seeing this to me C5 might be a
Temptation right oh let's connect the
pawns because I remember from the
speedrun that the best way to defend a
pawn is with another Pawn
but concrete considerations always take
precedent over these general rules
you're trying to make a move that
protects the queen and protects the pawn
at the same time and the move that
satisfies those constraints is Rook a to
D1 and that ends the game immediately we
don't we don't need to play it because
it renews the threat of d e and it keeps
the bishop trapped
Queen 66 yeah most popular wrong answer
to be awaited at all times and the game
is essentially over we've won a minor
piece and we also stand to trade Queens
very shortly because black essentially
has no way of avoiding the queen trade
and the queen trade is going to really
simplify things and help us win fast and
easily
black has a couple of other moves I
guess Queen E8 would be a way to avoid
the queen trade but that's that's not
serious okay so we can do a million
different things here to win I won't
belabor the point we have a really
pretty and very elegant tactical idea
though if we want to win a second piece
I just saw this so it starts with a move
that you should want to play anyway
there is a move that you should want to
play and you should want to play it
because it clearly induces weaknesses in
Black's position and it simplifies the
position so it checks off more than one
box what am I talking about once the
move Bishop takes F6 noticing of course
that the queen cannot recapture because
if Queen takes D7 so Bishop F6 black has
to play GF
and that creates massive weaknesses on
Black's King side but let's be more
specific what exactly how does it change
the king Side Pawn structure well you
might think and say the G7 pawn moves to
F6 that's all that's happened what is
the consequence of that what is the
result of that well the result of that
is that the G file has opened up so
there has appeared a new possibility
Queen D6 to G3 check but playing that
move immediately would be kind of lame
right because then the king would just
move over to h8 but we should keep that
in our pocket and we should make what
move before playing Queen G3 we combine
again several different factors in the
position you also know that the D file
[ __ ] stuff going stuff is going down
down the D file you play Rook 881 and if
the bishop moves then The Rook is
x-raying the queen and the queen drops
back to G3 with check and we win the
queen on d8 on d8 if black doesn't move
the bishop then we simply win the bishop
so that's how you construct a
combination and this is a combination it
doesn't involve any sacrifices but it's
a sequence of moves that has the aim of
delivering Checkmate or winning material
which is what uh I Define personally as
a combination
so Rook a to D1 hits the bishop seems to
have nothing to do with the King and yet
it does if the bishop moves Queen G3 is
a backward retreating discover check
against black skin
little combination here petite
combinazole
as they say in French
does it matter what tricky move not here
no here you can move either but Rook 81
is more open now Rook C7 is a move you
had to foresee
but the reason heavy pieces are bad
Defenders is because they're easy to
attack so at this point the move should
just come naturally to you you should
notice that the bishop on D7 is it's
it's hanging by a thread right it's on
life support so all you need to do is
play Knight to B5 this move really does
play itself if black takes the Knight
you're spoiled for choice but you can
still play Queen G3 check winning the
queen and then winning The Rook on C7 of
course the simpler move is just to take
the queen straight away also possible
if black doesn't react within the rook
and if black moves The Rook we take the
bishop and we're up to minor pieces
so I will say that of course you could
start with Rook a to D1 and you would
still be winning but it's less precise
after Rook 81 Bishop C6
right you can't then say oh now let's
take on F6 because then the queen can
already capture because the bishop has
moved away from the undefended square so
order of operations here is very
important another move that some people
suggest here is Knight to E4 terrible
move because black can actually take the
Knight simultaneously hitting White's
Queen
White's still winning after that by
Miracle but it's not to be advised
okay
nahil says I didn't see how we were
winning the bishop
well when if the bishop doesn't move
then we just take it with our Queen
right because we've got two attackers on
the bishop so either the bishop moves
then we win the black queen or the
bishop doesn't move and we win the
bishop
black reporting me as we speak well this
was
a nice game yeah
this was a pretty lethal a lethal
sequence of moves
and the decisive mistake if we if we're
speaking at a very high level now of
course the decisive mistake was Knight
D4 and I'll talk more about this after
the game Let's actually finish the game
in style let's make sure we're
not jumping the gun here
and queen G3 Chuck is the most accurate
move
opening up a discovery against the queen
which we take
do we take the bishop no we take the
Rook on the next move which is now
hanging
it has lost the support of the queen
which we've captured so everything falls
here
and now we're actually winning the
bishop it's hilarious we won the queen
then we won the rook and then we're
winning the bishop all in a row
just decisive lethal crushing
all right quick look over even though
this was a pretty straightforward game
so we will separate Queen 65. We won't
talk about this right now we'll face it
again I'm positive we'll face it again
uh and we'll be able to spend dedicated
time on it Knight F6 is a fundamentally
different line it's really not popular
anymore it's been played a lot by GM's
but it was black knows that he's worse
right and white is a million ways here
to cement the advantage so so you might
analyze with stockfish 15 and find that
Bishop B5 trick is not really the best
move I need to update my analysis of
this line I'm you know sharing thoughts
from like 2011 or 2012 which is when I
remember this from but still it's not
going to ruin the advantage so I will
mention that if if black plays Knight B
to D7 the simplest the simplest sequence
here is just to play D4 Knight takes D5
and Knight F3 just develop your freaking
pieces and if black plays A6 then you
can drop the bishop back to this nice
active Square on D3 okay so this is a a
straightforward advantage and after
Bishop D7 we play Bishop E2
Okay so
of course black should take the pawn on
D5
and the next couple of moves were
totally understandable and they were
valid by black
so C5 I actually like Knight F6 is fine
and here things go completely Haywire
for black obviously Knight C6 is just an
incredibly careless move that walks into
D5 our opponent just forgets about this
move
correct would have been to take on D4 to
finally eliminate the tension and only
after Knight takes D4 is it time to
develop the Knight and I think white is
slightly better after he castles but not
that much I mean black intake and start
simplifying and white is white is white
is a more pleasant position a space
advantage on the queen side it's nice
but it really might not be the best way
to punish the Knight F6 line
so another thing I forgot to point out
is just to show you on the board yc4 C6
and DC is not the way to go
so white might be not worse here but I
actually think white is worse after
Knight takes C6
by the way the best move here for white
is to play D4 and Knight C3 and this
transposes into the pawn of variation of
the Karo Khan It's a famous
transposition pawn off variation happens
takes takes the fortnite F6 Knight C3
the reason is because the same moves are
played they're just played in a
different order right in one order black
plays D5 C6 and then D5 and the other
black plays D5 and then C6 so it's not
mind-boggling that we get a a
transposition but in this position after
Knight F3 E5 I've talked about this type
of position through the lens of a
different line where in the Sicilian
white plays F4
now does anybody remember
what Black's move is in this position
and speed turkey it's an interesting
question let me get to it in a second
the move here is actually D5 immediately
striking ed5 we play Knight F6 C4 we
play E6 and we get a very similar type
of situation so you can find my speedrun
game on this line and listen to my
explanation because it's the same thing
it's the same weakness of the square
it's the same bad bishop and here you
also have uh the really bad move F4 so
this is even worse for white but
comparatively it's pretty simple Black's
got D4 Black's got Bishop coming out to
G4 the other visual coming out to C5 and
after D3 black can actually just
immediately strike with E4 black can
make this tactical and trade queens and
black still has a massive initiative in
the end game I mean just look at this
bishop B3 Bishop F5 castles Queen side
everything is coming out with Tempo and
this is just nasty nasty stuff right so
don't do that
now speed turkey is asking
how is it that Bishop B5 check gains the
tempo right as compared to the immediate
Bishop E2 well the answer is
basically first of all that here black s
Queen takes D5 which is an entire
additional option
second of all black can make the clever
move C6 here which is kind of annoying
right which which isn't as effective
here here of black plays C6 we take it
and after Knight C6 the concrete
difference is that we can actually play
D4 right in this move is a game changer
because it occupies the center if the
bishop is still on CA
then in this line we can't go D4 because
of Knight takes D4 so that's a very
subtle reason the bishop D7 is a
positive provocation but also and the
main reason is that it precludes it
precludes the tempo move Queen takes D5
and as far as I know white is still
better here so the answer is yes you
could play Bishop E2 first but Bishop B5
is slightly more accurate it gives back
more rope to hang himself so it's
concrete it's concrete
in any case after D5 the game is very
close to being over I mean that's how
powerful this Pawn is now what should
black have done in this position I
actually think amazingly enough that
Knight D4 is the right idea I think it's
basically the right move if black tries
to conserve material and play 97
okay this just looks horrible D6 has
come in and Knight B5 and I feel like
this is already winning for white so
that's kind of out of the question
Knight before is another move but here
we can chase the Knight further and then
still play D6 and this Pawn just looks
like a beast we can always support it
with the bishop
and in a line like this I mean come on
Knight A4 actually traps the queen which
is totally vicious like look at that
and Bishop A4 Queen A4 is just a total
Destruction and devastation
black is collapsing
oh a lot so anytime I plays D6 it just
it just hails destruction in its wake it
wreaks Havoc so the idea to sack upon
and develop is a good one and just file
this away in your sort of mental cabinet
this is a common idea you sacrifice a
pawn what do you sacrifice it for for
the right to develop a piece to gain a
Tempo like you're sacking for a Tempo
the tempo is used to get the dark scored
Bishop out so Knight T4 is the top
engine move
and as a result of the trade it's black
to play and black gets the bishop just
in time to D6 now obviously white can
trade it off with Bishop F4 it's plus
minus white is upon up there's no
compensation nobody's disputing that but
after the trade and the castle black can
still defend at least black is castled
at least black isn't checkmated
it's interesting says tube disaster that
a lot of chess moves are to provoke bad
moves by the opponent absolutely that's
that's a fascinating property of Chess
how as my friend used to call it you're
moving your opponent's pieces as well as
yours right and that's an art to move
your opponent's pieces onto the worst
possible squares for them
so anyways this might have been the
final chance
as it stood black inverted the move
order and now if black plays Ed we
actually might have ignored the pawn
entirely and gone something like Bishop
G5 just
you know quickly completing the
development this looks like a terrifying
position for Blackman just look at the
pressure on all of the diagonals maybe
the engine can hold this together but I
mean in in human games you often get
something like this and white just wins
a piece
so there were some move order issues but
I still think Ed was the best move
once our opponent like doesn't display a
sense of urgency and we get our pieces
out okay the situation now is is
absolutely dire the engine suggests to
take on C3 and to play some abstract
move like rookie a just sit tight try to
go E5
Black's position is crap I mean we can
go Rook AP1 and we can go rook fe1 and
we can bring the bishop to F3 I mean
white is just technically winning no
question about it
okay this was technically the way to
survive after Bishop I mean still rookie
eight here is a move or Bishop takes C3
but Bishop e76 just loses the game again
we put so much pressure our opponent
collapses
and uh most importantly Bishop C6 Rook a
to D1 is the crushing move because it
renews the threat of Bishop of D7 and at
the end of the day we're just up a full
piece and I won't elaborate at length
about how to win that end game
in the game we didn't need to win an end
game because we spotted the combination
we start by taking the Knight off the
board opening up the G file we conclude
by attacking the bishop getting it to
move and discovering the check against
Black's Queen
Rook C7 ip5 and this speaks for itself
we take the queen we take the rook and
we win the game so a 22 move game but a
lot happened we had an interesting
opening discussion I didn't delve too
deeply into the theory of this line
because it's so rare and because uh I
might actually analyze it and recommend
something different but hopefully you've
got the point of this bishop B5 Bishop
P2 line you understood the urgency of
playing D4 before Knight F3 you kind of
got a general sense for this structure
which is always a positive way to
further your understanding right every
structure every correlation of Pawns can
happen in one of your games and you're
like wait hey I know what the ideas are
here I know what I'm supposed to do I'm
going to go D5 D6 and that's how you
learn right you learn not just based on
tactics but you learn structures and
structures to find plans and plans can
be repeated so
uh you know so you shouldn't just think
of this as an opening speeder and you
should think of this as something that's
giving you ideas that you can use across
many different types of openings
so last thing I'll say D5 here
I talked about this we don't want to go
D5 before Knight C6
because it allows the bishop to blockade
us and we haven't even won a pawn
in contrast to that other line so here
black is actually totally fine
so it's very important to wait for black
to go Knight C6
okay guys
I will conclude here I'm I'm exhausted
but those were two awesome speedrun
games
I hope you guys enjoyed them once again
thank you all for uh for supporting me
the the subscriptions on Twitch YouTube
they help tremendously
this is my living so thank you everybody
for supporting hope you enjoyed hanging
out and I will see you guys tomorrow
thank you everybody for watching
have a good one see you tomorrow bye
[Music]